tonight for the first time 12 candidates
will face off on the same stage in a
democratic debate outside Columbus Ohio
a lots happened since the last debate
just one month ago two more people on
stage for instance CBS News political
contributors Robby Mook and Terry
Sullivan are here with what to expect
tonight
Robby was Hillary Clinton's campaign
manager in her 2016 presidential run
mr. Sullivan was Marco Rubio's campaign
manager in his 2016 bid good morning to
both you welcome Taryn let me start with
you
former Vice President Biden is still
facing criticism from President Trump
over his son hunter's ties in the
Ukraine does he have to respond to that
tonight he has to take the fight to
Donald Trump I mean this is actually a
huge opportunity that they've missed
this is you can either catch Spears in
politics or you can toss Spears catching
is it much fun it's not much fun you
just start throwing them in his he needs
to go on the attack and and prosecute
the case against Donald Trump on the
same issue well I wonder if hunter Biden
may have handed some Spears to the
opposition with an interview today I
want to play a bit of that sound this is
a hunter Biden responding to his joining
the Ukrainian energy company the board
and then dropping out let's listen to
that I'm a human you know what did I
make a mistake well maybe in the grand
scheme of things yeah but did I make a
mistake based upon some on ethical
lapses absolutely not
so Robbie does that put an end to it it
keeps close it's all over now look these
things are really hard I don't think
this is going away and there's no
perfect solution the campaign's just got
to manage through it look if I were
sitting next to Hunter Biden right now I
say buck up my friend I mean what what
happened here is nothing compared to
what the Trump family has done Wayne oh
well trademark said Ivanka getting
trademarks in China while she's serving
in the West Wing you know you've got Don
junior over doing an event with the
prime minister of India to sell condos I
mean what he did is nothing compared to
that he just sat on a board he wasn't
doing events with foreign but that's
where we're at that it's about what
about ISM I mean it profit off of the
of his father's name and and you know at
least he's taking responsibility for it
but it does look kind of awful like the
whip I was venting actually Hunter Biden
what I'd say is don't ever go on TV
again ever you look awful
like you look guilty but you know this
is look this is kind of the evil genius
of Donald Trump he has a big problem and
he casts it onto his opponent yeah we're
hearing lock him up again it's it's it's
mind-boggling that the Trump is somehow
on offense on an issue where he has
serious voter what about Bernie Sanders
tonight is this a pivotal moment for him
and his campaign his first after the
heart attack I definitely think so he
needs to project to his supporters like
I'm all-in or not I'm healthy yeah yeah
I think that's part of it but I think
people are also looking for signals you
know cuz he said well I'm gonna change
the nature of my campaign and so on they
seem to retract that he's got either
tonight he's like all in we're charging
forward we're gonna we're gonna take the
mantle back or not and look the other
thing I think you might see from him is
he might be saying to Elizabeth Warren
hey I was for this stuff I wrote these
bills I was through this stuff long
before you got on the train kind of an
attack we haven't really seen that but
he needs to I mean his regardless of his
physical health his his campaigns health
is on life support yeah he either - no
pun intended
no pun intended he either takes the
fight to Elizabeth Warren tonight and
fights on the issues or he functions
drops out
I mean he's losing ground her her
support her gains are coming from him
not Joe Biden I know but last time you
were here Terry you said that Elizabeth
Warren to quote you exactly had the
worst chance of beating Donald Trump in
the general election but she's rising in
the polls do you still think that's true
yeah I don't think yeah absolutely
numbers going out amongst Democrats it's
Democrat primary voters I mean you gotta
think what these primary voters are
super small universe and so it you know
sometimes you have to do things to win a
primary that hurt you in a general and
that's what frankly all of these
Democrat candidates are doing right now
on things like health care people on
stage tonight yes what can we really
expect to get out of this Connor who's
gonna fall off the end of that stage
before the next debate yeah well that's
a question of fundraising basic online
fundraising right effectively I think
that I think look they're gonna be
speaking in short clips
I think this format will lend itself to
people throwing spears frankly so I
would look for some of those middle to
bottoms
candidates to go I think tulsi gabbard
you know we've seen her in the past she
didn't take on any water for going after
Kamala Harris I wouldn't be surprised if
she goes after Warren and some of these
middle tier candidates they got a
breakout what roles the impeachment
inquiry you're gonna have in this debate
do you think Robby how important is it
gonna be you know that's really
interesting that's something I'm gonna
be curious to look at my guess is
candidates are not gonna lean into that
because the problem with doing that is
it says well let's just get rid of
Donald Trump through a vote not saying
hey let's beat him let's beat him on the
merits I'm ready to defeat him in an
election so I think there's weakness and
kind of hitting on that too hard I think
you'll see candidates say it's wrong he
should be impeached but then pivot out
right away to say but I'm prepared to
beat him on my own is this the last
chance for some of these these moderate
these these candidates who were at me
because there's only three candidates in
double digits right now in Bernie
Sanders is in danger of dropping below
that is this the last chest for some of
these other candidates for some of them
but but I mean look you don't have to
necessarily be in double digits right
now if you look at people who did I mean
look he's still in a good position I
think he's a little bit of the sleeper
candidate who can when these other ones
start really pounding on each other can
rise up and so I think he's got the
money to do it does he have a better
chance of beating Donald Trump
absolutely yeah 100% 100% was likable
because when she speaks she's not like
yeah yeah right the look at the at the
end of the day the way she wags her
finger when she talks and things like
that her video she's awkward she's not
comfortable in her own skin and that's
nothing to do with her being a woman or
versus a man that's interesting listen
when we went to the green room before
they came on I said what's going to
happen tonight and Terry goes the
Nationals are going to win the National
Robin Terry thank you for being here